[Musique]
et c'est une aventure que j'ai vécu il y
a 20 ans où on est décidé de partir
faire le tour de France à pied pendant 3
mois 2500 km pour aller ouvrir un
théâtre chaque soir dans un village où
il y avait jamais eu théâtre où les gens
découvert un spectacle pour la première
fois de leur vie je raconte cette
aventure avec plus de 22 personnages que
j'interprète seuls sur scène et donc
voilà c'est un combat théâtre
complètement immersif puisque les gens
font vraiment l'aventure les spectateurs
sont vraiment ambiancés parce que toute
la bande son a été créée avec des bruits
de campagne de plein de choses et la
mise en scène de Clotilde d'agneau aide
à cela aussi pour pour vraiment que le
spectateur soit vraiment en symbiose
avec avec le comédien sur scène
[Musique]
ça fait 20 ans que ça me trottait dans
la tête et à chaque fois je racontais
des anecdotes qui ne sont arrivés
pendant tout ce périple les gens me
disent mais c'est pas possible c'est
incroyable ce que vous avez vécu et je
me suis bon je vais peut-être en faire
un seul en scène et chose faite
maintenant depuis un an que je joue
[Musique]
pour rire pour avoir plein d'émotions
c'est un spectacle qui traverse toutes
les émotions imaginables comme je le
disais j'interprète 22 personnes sur
scène qui se donnent la réplique en
permanence le son les lumières sont
assez dingues et c'est vrai que les gens
à la fin souvent me disent on a
l'impression d'avoir fait les 2500 km
avec vous et on s'est régalé on a vécu
une vraie aventure ça a vraiment un road
movie mais à pied donc si vous voulez
faire du sport tout en restant assis
venez donc à 20h30 jeudi soir le 22 à la
Royal Factory
[Musique]